what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the most recent
developments in black clover including
the incredible limit surpassing battle
between Dante and Yami and the
long-awaited return of hasta to the
battlefield things are already hot in
black clover and they are heating up
even more so let's get into it if you
enjoy the black clover content on this
channel and you want us to keep it go
and please leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar or you just
haven't subscribed make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications the only way to make sure
that you really will be notified by
YouTube is to click that bell and select
the option that says oh you can also hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram ads anime
uproar finally this video will contain
black holder manga spoilers as always in
a video like this one we are dealing
with the latest black clover story
development so please proceed with
caution you have been warned at the end
of the previous chapter we say Yami's
new dark magic attack absolutely
annihilate Dante's body this attack
officially translated as death thrust
completely destroyed
Dante's torso and so basically all that
was left of him were his head and his
arms and legs for any normal person that
would have been the end of the line they
would have been dead on the spot
but in my previous video I warned that
Dante's death is highly unlikely
Dante possesses immense demonic power
and he also possesses that weird flesh
magic that allows him to heal even the
deadliest wounds so my strong suspicion
was that Dante would survive despite the
severity of his injuries I also
speculated that Yami likely won't be
able to defeat Dante on his own he is
going to need help from his squad and
from asta in particular and that is
exactly what this latest chapter has
confirmed Dante is utterly shocked that
a normal human has been able to do this
to him he and Lucifer can't believe that
a human who can stand up to a demon and
demon magic actually
exists however along with being
surprised Dante is also intrigued by
Yami suka hito and his magic as I had
suspected Dante is indeed able to use
his grotesque flesh magic to repair his
body yet again and as he does this he
thanks Yami for providing him with this
challenge dante then explains that his
original magic is this strange flesh or
body magic that allows him to heal his
wounds but once he was possessed by
lucifer his original magic was boosted
and became much stronger that must be
why dante is able to recover so quickly
from even the deadliest injuries
including this latest one which would
have killed anyone else according to
Dante this flesh magic also prevents him
from dying or getting old which if true
is just incredibly old P even in the
world of black over not only is Dante
incredibly strong he can also keep this
same level of power and energy for
eternity because he will never age the
black bulls are understandably stunned
by just how broken Dante is but Dante
says that he actually doesn't like using
his flesh magic he thinks it's ugly and
every time he regenerates it deforms his
body but he couldn't help but to use it
against the army because Yami's power is
just that impressive by the way in the
past I'd always assumed that this flesh
magic was the demons magic and that
gravity magic was Dante's original magic
and that's just because his original
magic is so demonic and when he
regenerates Dante reminds me a lot of
Zuck red and how he would regenerate his
own body during the big fight against
the clover Kingdom mages however it
turns out that gravity magic is
Lucifer's magic because the body magic
thing is Dante's original magic I saw
that a few you guys at the comments had
this opinion so kudos to you you nailed
it the epic battle between Yami and
Dante continues as Yami keeps using
death thrust to destroy large chunks of
Dante's body but Dante just keeps
regenerating his flesh over and over
again nonetheless Dante continues to be
impressed by ami and he admits that in
terms of battle skill Yami is actually
ahead of him in
fact danta can't help being jealous of
Yami
it seems that part of the reason why
Dante is so impressed with Yami is
because his incredibly broken magic
makes him pretty much invincible for
that reason no matter how hard his
opponent works and no matter how hard
his opponent tries at the end of the day
Dante always wins he cannot die so he
just keeps coming back until his
opponent is destroyed but Yami has given
Dante a run for his money
something that Dante doesn't see very
often so Dante finds this to be very
impressive as the fight continues Yami
is really giving it as all and pushing
beyond his limits but he just can't
finish Dante off no matter how badly he
keeps getting destroyed Dante just keeps
regenerating auste who is still on the
ground but he is conscious and watching
the fight realizes that Yami won't be
able to keep this up for very much
longer
and in fact moments later Yami admits
this himself when he says that this
one-on-one battle is over Yami simply
cannot defeat Dante by himself
despite his unparalleled strength and
incredible magic at the end of the day
dante cannot defeat a demon with
infinite mana who just doesn't die at
least not on his own so does this mean
that Yami is going to give up of course
not my boy Yami is not the type of
person to ever give up yes he admits
that he can't beat Dante by himself and
that is why he invites
auste to come fight with him after
hearing this hasta gets the shot of
motivation that he needed he musters up
the strength to stand up and grab his
sword and in the very last panel of the
chapter the two Black Bull legends Yami
and asta are standing side by side as
they prepare to face off against Dante
wow what a great chapter and what an
awesome fight this has been so far Yami
is surpassing his limits unlocking new
overpowered spells but it's still not
enough Yami still needs help and that is
one of the things that I love about
black clover sure the characters do get
stronger relatively quickly and
sometimes they can power up by getting
emotional or surpassing their limits
like in every Shonen but that alone is
enough to defeat a villain of the
caliber of Dante teamwork is essential
and as we've seen in the past teamwork
is a major aspect of the black clover
power system you can work hard and get
super angry and surpass your limits and
that's all great but that's not always
enough for most of the major battles you
still need to learn to fight using
teamwork you need to learn to combine
various different magic types in complex
and strategic ways and for me personally
that is one of the most interesting
aspects of black clover and speaking of
combining interesting types of magic I
can't wait to see dark magic and anti
magic working together against Dante on
its own even the super rare and crazy
strong dark magic wasn't enough to beat
Dante but when you bring anti magic into
the mix who knows what might happen if
Yami and asta can come up with an
effective combat strategy maybe hasta
can use his anti magic to prevent Dante
from repairing his flesh at just the
right moment and this would then allow
the army to defeat Dante for good with a
strategically placed dark magic attack
I'm thinking that something like this
might happen eventually but before that
I'm expecting an absolutely incredible
battle that will test the limit of all
three of these mages no offense to the
golden dawn or to Noel and the crew but
this battle against Dante is so much
more interesting to me than the battles
against xenon and Miggy Kula we know
that eventually xenon and mega kula will
be involved in the final showdown
but so far dante versus Yami has been
the best fight and the highlight of this
entire arc for me and now with hasta
joining the fray as well it's going to
get even better I know I say this a lot
but I really can't wait to see what
happens next
oh and I almost forgot about the Black
Bull spy inside the spade kingdom the
one who uses shadow magic that is also
the character that I suspect of being
the Black Bolt vice-captain and I'm so
curious to learn more about him or her
it is very likely that this secret black
bull will join the battle against the
dark triad in the very near future
I am absolutely stoked to learn more
about this mysterious black bull and
about shadow magic in
particular well let me know what you
guys think are you loving the Yami
versus Dante battle as much as I am and
how do you think the addition of hasta
and anti magic to the mix is going to
change the course of the battle our Yami
and us are going to be able to take
Dante out or will they still fall short
and something else will have to happen
before Dante goes down finally what do
you think about the Black Bull spy we
haven't talked about this character in a
while but when do you think this
character will make his or her
appearance again please share your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more black Laura content on the
channel please don't forget to leave a
like it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime or or you just
haven't subscribed don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
hitting that Bell and then selecting the
option that says all if you don't do
that you're gonna miss a lot of our
videos even if you're subscribed it's
just how you do works you can also hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram ads anime
up rule I want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime upper patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thanks to all of our the one
tier patrons to want to rise above all
other clans including Ingrid ah a Lola
Madame the world Steelers acquired
respect but they heffa Jonathan King
Brandon Avila's Papa Smurf the school
bus King riser emperor otaku Ricardo
Martinez Thomas Jones Kinmen Oh Michael
Hyde and Jade and the vector and I can't
forget all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
eldress Anatole Kazuki on hell crews
critics beep Joe Stanton very Gucci
Alicia
ahktar Jessica Kayla fond Honoka me and
water
Bonnie parks Zoda art 12 Roth we need a
hora Kraken are l's and deadly Saint if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you please
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our peach and exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]